a historic expansion of Nevada's highest
level of care hospital we're talking
about UMC University Medical Center on
West Charleston right near Rancho now
Brian will was there as leaders from
around our community turned over the
first piece of dirt to begin the project
UMC breaks ground on its largest
renovation project in its 92-year
history Clark County Commissioner
William McCurdy thinks this is a great
investment for Las Vegas we want our
residents to know that this is for them
and when they need it and we are
grateful to invest in the community
Mason van holling the CEO of UMC says
this 55 million dollar project funded by
umc's capital budget will modernize the
entire campus two new healing Gardens
new lighting new robust Landscaping new
entrance off of shadow new efis and so
we're very excited about the project the
upgrades will also include new signage
upgraded parking lots and improved
traffic and pedestrian access we've been
planning this project for a few years
probably about six years and then
unfortunately with the pandemic had to
put that on ice but we're we've got it
back on target Monday signing of the
first beam marks the start of this
project which is expected to be
completed before UMC celebrates its
100th birthday it's great to know that
by the time that we do they're going to
have a new world-class revitalized
facility and UMC campus construction
begins on Tuesday with the renovations
and projects scheduled to be completed
by summer of 2025. reporting near the
medical center Brian will 8 news now the
hospital will remain open during
construction there should be little
impact to patients and those working
there now you can see more detailed
specs of what campus will look like when
finished you'll find that over on
8newsnow.com